on n'est pas un sport mixte
par exemple on avait il s'est paré
vachement les filles et les garçons et
par exemple il y avait des choses que
les garçons faisait pas les filles
après il ya un peu de discrimination
aussi dans le sens où mais je vais pas
dire de la discrimination négative dans
le sens où par exemple les filles nous
nous demande d'être beaucoup plus souple
que les garçons on va demander des
qualités que les garçons n'ont pas
forcément besoin
donc il va y avoir des aspects sur
lesquels on va devoir beaucoup plus
travaillé que forcément eu après c'est
le patinage qui demande ça un gars enfin
même si ça commence à évoluer on voit
des garçons faire des choses des
éléments de souplesse
on voit des filles faire des choses
beaucoup plus masculine est beaucoup
plus tonique
donc ça évolue mais on reste ça reste
quand même un peu dans ce sens là il ya
une énorme discrimination au niveau des
notes c'est qu'en fait
sur l'aspect chorégraphique les filles
ont un coefficient beaucoup plus
inférieur c'est à dire qu'au niveau des
notes on pourra pas je dit pas jamais
mais on pourra ça c'est très difficile
de dépasser les garçons parce que sur
l'aspect chorégraphique
nous on a un coefficient de 2,060 et les
garçons 2 1
ça veut dire que par exemple si tous les
juges me met
j'espère à quatre ou cinq ça va faire
fois à 0,60 et les garçons ça va faire x
1 donc le problème c'est qu'au niveau
des notes on sera toujours en dessous
des garçons donc techniquement certaines
filles ont vraiment une technique je
dirais égal ou même supérieure aux
garçons donc sur la note technique on
pourrait les dépasser
parce que la note technique c'est la
même mais sur la note artistique c'est
impossible du coup nos scores répondent
ils peuvent jamais monter autant que
ceux des garçons donc sage est on
vraiment debout
notre système de notation comme il est
il a été instaurée en 2000 et depuis ce
moment là ils l'ont instauré comme ça
donc le problème c'est que depuis
personne je sais pas c'est enfin c'est
vraiment pas une question qui se pose
chaque année chaque année vous tous les
ans ils vont revoir les règlements donc
ils vont revoir le système j'ai pas
chaque pirouette quel point elles valent
ou machin mais ils vont pas revoir ce
truc là est 5e ça fait un petit peu râlé
quand même quand tu sais que tu peux pas
comparer ses scores avec ceux des
garçons alors qu on a exactement le même
temps de programmes et le même contenu
d'éléments pourtant on n'a pas le même
si le même système de notation non
pourra jamais être au niveau
je pratique un sport qui est assez
exigeant au niveau de l'alimentation
donc je sais que donc il ya eu pas mal
et c'est là où il ya une grosse
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes c'est que nous par exemple comme
je parlais à vendre cette période à 16
ans où on a tendance à prendre du poids
et bas chez que par exemple dans les
sports exigeant comme le patinage le
dire aussi la danse je sais la gym tous
ces sports là où faut vraiment avoir une
ligne très très bonne hygiène de vie
et ou cd sport qui se pratique jeune et
je sais qu'il ya pas mal de d'abus au
niveau de cette rigueur là et que
beaucoup inculte les mauvaises valeurs
je sais que des délégations ou des
fédérations qui disait je sais pas de
qui met fin qui par exemple y avait pas
mal de boulimie et ça a choqué personne
c'était totalement normal donc ça moi je
trouve ça vraiment pas normal de de
laisser faire ces choses là alors que ça
reste quand même des maladies enfin ça
reste des maladies mentales donc il faut
traiter ces des maladies qui peuvent
être très dangereuses il ya eu des cas
de mortalité dans le patinage de
boulimie donc et d'anorexie donc c'est
vraiment des choses donc il faut faire
attention on nous dit il faut que tu
perds du poids il faut que tu passes
devant toi tu vas te regardes et tu vas
dire non mais c'est pas possible il faut
que je perde du poids alors que c'est
c'est pas comme ça et tu vas le faire de
la mauvaise manière et ça va être ça va
être vachement destructeur et donc quand
tu regardes les trois quarts à elles
n'ont pas confiance en elle elle se
trouve trop grosse
on va essayer surtout ça la grosse
discrimination quoi
[Musique]